talk um so this talk is based on a line
of recent work over the past uh two
years or so um and these are all the
co-authors that have worked on uh line
of work and uh quite a number of them
are in the audience
today uh so let's begin with the basic
definitions I know everyone here is an
expert already but just to start us off
with um we'll Define the mainos flow
problem um so so for this problem as
input we're given a graph G with n
vertices and M directed
edges we have vertex demands and these
demands add up to zero so positive
demand means you want um flow coming in
and negative demand means you want to
send flow out and we also have Edge
capacities uh non- Negative Edge
capacities and also costs for every
Edge and the output for the algorithm
should be a flow minimize ing the total
cost and satisfying the constraints and
routing the
demand okay so um we're also going to
talk about General linear program
solvers so this is um a general linear
program uh written in standard
form and uh just to remark so here we're
using the constraint Matrix a and a is
going to be uh of n by m so m is the
number of variables um which might get a
little bit confusing but the reason we
choose to do it this way is because for
flow problems m is the number of edges
so um we want that to be representing
our number of
variables so for General linear programs
they don't necessarily correspond to any
graphs but we still want to be able to
associate a graph with these linear
programs so what we do is we um take we
look at the constraint Matrix so we look
at the Matrix a which has n rows and we
assign one vertex to each row um and for
the M Columns of a we basically treat
each column as a hyper Edge or
equivalently you can think of it as a
click so in a column you have a certain
number of non-zero entries um and uh the
hyper Ed will contain all the vertices
for which the row is nonzero at that
column okay so
um I hope that's clear and the reason we
Define this uh dual graph this way is
because in the case of um the main cost
flow problem uh if we look at this uh
constraint Matrix be transpose we treat
that as a in the original um General
linear program formulation then um B
transpose here is the adjacency Matrix
of the input graph G and the way we've
defined the Dual graph means that um the
Dual graph of this linear program
formulation is exactly the
adjacency Matrix of the input graph
G okay so um stepping back a little bit
we also want to Define uh the treewidth
of a linear program so again General
linear programs do not necessarily
correspond to uh any graphs but because
we've defined this dual graph we can
talk about the tree width of the Dual
graph as a
graph so we say the tree width of the
linear program is the tree width of the
Dual graph
and similarly um we want to talk about
separable linear programs and here we
say um a linear program is separable if
the Dual graph is
separable and we'll get into like
separability definitions a little bit
later so we talked about main cost flow
lar
programs um so these are some of the
current state-of-the-art results for
research and dist Direction and in my
talk I'll be focusing on um these five
that I've highlighted and basically
they're all on graphs um or general
linear programs that exhibit like
specific structural properties so we
have planer graphs we have um tree width
te graphs um and then we have Alpha
separable linear programs corresponding
to Alpha separable
graphs and yeah so all three are um they
admit a very nice balance separators
that will uh really make use of in our
algorithms and for these classes of
problems we have um uh the state of
the-art uh result um so we have nearly
linear time algorithm for mainos flow on
planer graphs um and that was an
improvement from uh m to the 1.5 or also
n to the 1.5 because m equals M and N
are on the same order um the end to the
1.5 result is the steel maintain result
um
and
um I think that's about all I wanted to
say about uh the results we get in our
algorithm okay um so let's jump into to
what happens in these algorithms so
we'll be using interior Point method as
um is common in this line of
work and just as a very general brief
overview um in the interior Point method
usually uh so here we have the polytope
uh so here I'm only uh talking about the
Primal solution but we're doing Primal
dual uh Inter Point method so here is
the feasible um set so this polytope and
this is the optimal solution we're going
to
and the red line here is um the central
path so the idea of uh the interior
Point method is that um you start off uh
with some point on the central path that
you're trying
to
um so first you need to find a feasible
Point inside the interior Point inside
the polytope and then you try to move uh
towards some point on the central path
by taking a Newton step and then you
basically move along the central path to
a different point and you move your
solution to try to follow uh that point
and then you um on the central path you
take uh
another you move along the central path
again from the second point to the third
point and you want to move your solution
um closer to the third point on the
central path and um by doing this you
just kind of follow this uh Central path
towards the optimal
solution
okay and in robust interior Point
methods what we do is a little bit
different so we have our initial Point
um initial feasible point in the
polytope and what we do is we also keep
an approximation of the solution so X1
is our current solution and then
xar one is the approximation to the
current solution and this is going to be
a coordinate wise
approximation and now um we want to move
uh so basically X1 is kind of
corresponding to this point P star one
on the central path and now we kind of
want to move closer to P star 2 so in
regular interior Point method we would
um use X1 to calculate the direction uh
to go in ter uh in order to get closer
to P star 2 but with robust interior
Point method we use xar to calculate the
direction we want to move in so what
happens is that um
uh because we're using the information
on xar instead of a x um we could take
bigger uh
steps uh that bring us further away um
from the central
path um okay and then we get to uh our
second Point X2 and we also maintain an
approximation xbar uh that is um
coordinate wise close to X2 and we use
xar again to find uh the step we want to
take to get closer to P star
3 and then we find um the approximation
to
X3 okay so the guarantees here are um
that it still converges in a square root
M Times log one over Epsilon
iterations and also we know that the
steps have bounded to Norm and these
will be uh really important for our data
structures okay so now that we have
talked about how robust interior Point
method works we can basically say we
want to apply uh robust interior Point
methods to our linear programs and this
reduces to two data structure problems
so first is we have a current solution X
for this robust interior Point method um
it's iterating it's updating at every
step by some Delta X so that's the step
we're
taking um to move closer to the next
point on the central path
and um we know that uh the step that
we're taking is going to be of the form
uh p subw v where um V and W are
functions of xar so basically we're
using xar to compute uh the direction
that we're taking and also um we're
waiting it so that uh we stay within the
feasible
set okay so in regular interior Point
method V and W would be functions of X
instead of xar so that's the
difference um and here this p subw is an
approximate uh L2 projection onto
feasible sub onto the feasible Subspace
so for some of our papers we use the
exact uh L2 projection and for um the
case of flow problems we can have a
approximate solution approximate
projection which allows us to have even
faster running
times and the techniques that we'll use
uh in order to accomplish this Dynamic
algorithm is to um for part one do
Matrix and inverse Matrix maintenance in
order to maintain this uh P subw so at
every iteration because W is changing
this Matrix is changing and we need to
be able to um always use the latest uh
Matrix and then the second technique is
that at every step we update X by a step
but we don't want to explicitly compute
every coordinate of this update so we'll
have an implicit representation of X and
this also means that um at every step
it's not very easy to just get all the
information you want out of um the
current solution X so we have to be
clever about what information we
actually need from X um and when we want
to be able to um access
everything okay so part one was uh to
maintain the current solution X and part
two is um we need to maintain the
approximation
xar and here we can actually reduce this
problem to finding Heavy Hitters in X so
basically finding uh large coordinates
in X and um the difficulty here is that
because X is not represent presented
explicitly we can't just look through
the vector that would cost um order of
end time so uh we want to be able to
find Heavy Hitters quickly and we give a
probabilistic um algorithm for this
part okay so uh those are the problems
that we're going to be solving again um
yeah I just ask quick what's the
intuition for what's the difference
between X and xar again like you could X
but why are you using X instead oh okay
so X is the exact uh solution of our
current um IPM iteration and the idea is
that Computing x x is going to be
expensive so typically it will take
order of M times m is the length of the
vector and because xar is only an
approximation to X um you can imagine if
when we take a step we don't have to
update every coordinate of xar um so now
we have guarantees on how many
coordinates of xar we actually want to
update okay so we have this like
implicit representation of X but we
don't actually use it when we're making
the the next step we use xar instead um
so we don't use it to calculate where we
calculate this step but we need to make
that step from the current X okay okay I
got it
thanks um yeah okay so these are the the
problems that we're trying to solve and
um this implicit representation of X is
what we called um the multiscale
representation uh in this paper um that
was about linear programs for low true
withth matrices um and this is really
long and goha worked really hard on it
but now it's all been simplified so you
don't need to read that paper
anymore and we actually um in our latest
paper uh simplified all the data
structures so so now we have something
um a lot more modular and the theorem
basically says if the update to X is up
the form
um this thing then we have efficient
data structures for everything right so
the update is p subw v and we want to be
able to write this expression as uh this
Delta NAA and I'll explain what that is
um so this Delta is going to be what we
call a tree operator and the na is an
inverse tree operator so one is triangle
and one is upside down um and both of
them are functions of the weight uh the
weights W from the IPM because of course
this is a factorization of the Matrix p
subw and now when we say efficient data
structures um we're going to mean um
like how fast we can do all the updates
we depend on how fast we can work with
these two
matrices
okay so um let's uh talk about how to
actually get these um tree operators and
inverse tree operators so now let's talk
about balanced separators um in that
direction so given a graph G um and a
constant B um and here we also say we're
going to assign some weights to the
vertices we say a Vertex set is a b
balanced um vertex separator so sorry B
balanced vertex separator if um when you
remove the set from G you get two
disconnected components A and B and both
of them contain at most uh small B
fraction of the total
weight um and of course there are um
there's the famous theorem by Lipton
Narin saying that planer graphs have um
square root and size
separators um the second one is not
really a theorem it's more like just the
property of separable graphs that n to
the alpha separable graphs have size n
to the alpha
separators and finally tree with t
graphs have size T separators and really
this is um the key property that we'll
use and these are you know what
differentiates the different cases that
we have in our results um and then the
framework we have applies to all three
cases um so yeah let's now talk about
how to use a balance separator to
decompose a graph and we'll use um this
planer graph uh the grid graph on N
vertices as an example so what we'll do
is we'll recursively use a balanced
separator um to decompose the graph
until every piece is um very small so in
this case we want there to be no more uh
non-trivial balance
separator um okay so for
example uh one balance separator could
be the
third column in the middle because when
you remove these vertices you get two
halves uh you got two halves that are
balanced okay so um by applying this
separation recursively we can get uh
what we call a separator tree um and how
this works is we start off at the root
with the original graph and here we say
this is at level zero and it's the
zeroth uh node at that level um we find
a balance separator and then we split up
the two sides and for the edges within
the balanced separator we can just
partition them arbitrarily to the two
sides okay so then we have um two NOS uh
at the at level one and again we will
find a balanced separator in this node
which will take to be this part in the
middle and that separates it into two
smaller pieces
and we do the same thing on the other
side so edges in the middle um get
partitioned
arbitrarily and we can see that you know
the height of this tree is going to be a
log of n um it has constant degree each
node you know represents the subgraph of
the original graph and we get down to
constant size Leaf
nose um some other interesting
properties so the union of nose at a
level is going to be the original graph
um and also the edges uh Al together the
nodes partition the entire Edge set and
another thing is that if you look at two
sibling noes so these two um the
intersection of their vertex sets is the
separator at the parent
level okay and some other notation um
that are pretty important for us so the
boundary of one of these pieces is going
to be basically um the knows where um
this piece is attached to the rest of
the graph on so the boundary for this
bottom piece would be
um these vertices and then those
vertices and yeah so so the separator
tree actually gives us a very natural
partition of the vertices and edges in
the um original graph and they'll be
necessary for defining um the tree
operators
okay so we have you know this very
interesting separator tree with a lot of
structure and now we want to say okay we
use the separator tree to recursively
Factor the symmetric Matrix um which
shows up in this uh projection Matrix
piece of
w um and you know here's the the chu
decomposition formula and basically um
you know we have one uh lower triangular
Matrix and then an upper triangular
Matrix on the right and in the middle is
a block triangular Matrix and this one
here is the sh complement um which has
lots of interesting properties on its
own and um this we call it the short
complement of L onto C and this again is
a symmetric Matrix and it's supported on
the vertex s c so we can recursively
apply the sheski decomposition to this
short
complement and how do we partition uh
the vertex s into f and c
um all the partitions are determined
using the way we've partitioned the
vertices on the separator
tree and it just happens that um you
know sh compliments they have very good
properties especially for this case so
um there's transitivity and
decomposability which works really well
you know on this recursive
tree so with that we can decompose um P
subw um into something of this for form
so every Matrix Pi here like pi to the I
um that represents something going on on
the I level of the separator tree and
basically we have some matrices that are
associated with each node of the
tree okay and remember our goal was to
be able to write this p subw as a tree
operator and an inverse tree operator um
and we want to be able to decompose this
Matrix um based on a separator tree so
this is starting to look really
good um and indeed uh you know um we can
show that the first part is a tree
operator the second part is an inverse
tree
operator so um what ends up happening is
that um I didn't Define these matrices L
uh superscript H but they are defined
here they're defined recursively using
recursive properties of short complement
so that we start off um with uh
definitions for the base cases at the
bottom and then this L Matrix um at the
node h10 is going to be just the
function of the L Matrix at s two
children
knows and now we can talk about like
solving the Matrix maintenance problem
so we want to be able to maintain these
ow matrices and there are also other uh
L matrices other matrices and also
inverses to be
maintained um because uh you'll notice
here that this is a function of the
weights that are changing but um for
every bottom level L Matrix notice that
it's only a function of the weights on
the edges in this piece so it's quite
small and it gets uh bigger as we go
up so um to maintain the matrices then
we notice that if the weights change as
some of the edges we only need to update
um the bottom piece that contains that
edge and all of its ancestors so we
don't need to update the entire tree and
that's why um using this tree structure
we're able to maintain the Matrix
inverses so much faster than um just
that Brute Force
maintenance okay and if we very
carefully
um compute the time it costs to do these
maintenance then we get
um basically the theorem of our uh
upcoming paper in soda saying that for
separable graphs um this works out to
give us efficient algorithms for solving
linear
programs running a little bit low on
time okay so for flow problems so so far
we've been talking about the general
frame framework and general linear
programs and for flow problems
specifically um we know that if the lp
is flow problem then this AWA transpose
is a weighted L plastin because a here
will be an adjacency Matrix and with
weighted PLS um they can be solved in
nearly linear time and also we can take
um approximate short complement that are
sparse um and because of these two tools
uh together we get nearly linear time M
cost flow on Plano graphs and then also
M Time Square Root n time M cost flow on
tree with t graphs so we don't get this
for General graphs because um both of
these are
lacking General linear
programs okay and now I'm gonna skip all
of these slides suan told me that I
would run out of time and he was totally
right um but it's fun it's there's a a
lot of Animation about what
happens
[Music]
um okay and I didn't talk about implicit
representations and heavy hitter
detection uh for you know this IPM
solution X but both of them rely on this
tree structure so X will be represented
as a tree operator applied to a vector
and as the tree operator gets updated
again we say we don't have to update the
entire tree we don't have to update the
operator on every Edge and we can limit
um the amount of updates and therefore
um bound the running time and with heavy
hitter detection um so we have X
represented as a tree operator times a
vector
um and the idea here is to sketch the
tree operator using uh Johnson linen St
sketch um and it works out magically
that we're able to do heavy hitter
detection
okay and um it's been kind of a long
line of work and all the theorems are a
little bit disjoint but uh if you want a
nice reference in the future then
hopefully I'll get everything tidied up
in my thesis so shamess flug um yeah and
thank
you thank
you think we have time for one or two
quick
questions just a very simple question
what what is the running time then uh
the nearly linear running
time can you say can you be a little bit
more specific oh yeah um nearly linear
in the input H size so for planer graphs
um because is it a is is it m times a
polylog or is m m to the one plus little
o of one oh M times the polylog and what
is the polylog do you have an upper
bound uh the degree not not that bad
like three or four oh great and and I
guess one more question I mean the the
idea of using separators um in cheski
decomposition goes back
to uh LP and Rose Taran and Ned
dissection but clearly you're using more
much more modern techniques I'm
wondering if you could sort
of
uh briefly say how how uh what
techniques you're using here I mean you
mentioned heavy hit for example which
was definitely not used and this tree
representation yeah are those the main
tools are there other tools that you're
using um on top of on top of the the the
old idea I think I covered pretty much
all of the main tools so the Heavy
Hitters for detecting large um
coordinates when uh you know the vector
is represented in this tree structure um
yeah the tree operator and the tree
structure um and
and yeah I guess that's that's all yeah
yeah but the the nest dissection of
course is very old and it's a semino
piece of work thank
you or a quick
question right thanks Sally uh let's
thank you for the talk now we now have a
30 minute
[Applause]
break